-Our first guest
is a world renowned chef
and Emmy-nominated TV host.
His new show, which is great,
"Next Level Chef,"
airs Wednesdays at 9:00 p.m.
on Fox.
Here is Gordon Ramsay,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, bud.
Welcome back to our show.
-Thank you, mate.
Good to see you.
-It is lovely to see you.
Before we start, please,
I was just gonna ask you, 'cause
I've never done this before
when we've been on the show --
please don't yell at me,
and -- or curse or call --
call me an idiot or anything.
Just this one time, Gordon.
This is a time
to change things around.
Change is good, you know?
-Change is good,
but sometimes, the occasional
[bleep] comes out.
-All right, here we go.
All right, now look.
-Okay.
Come on.
-I knew this was just gonna
go off the rails already.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I wanted
to ask you?
I don't think anyone's
ever asked you.
'Cause I know you're married --
your lovely wife
and your beautiful family.
But when you get married
and you're -- you're an
unbelievable chef
like Gordon Ramsay is,
do you over-obsess
about the food?
What was the food
at your wedding?
-Oh, God,
that's a good question.
This year we celebrate 25 years,
which is great. So, uh...
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-We had something like
150 chefs turn out
for this wedding.
And we got married back in 1996
at the Café Royal.
And so I decided
to keep it really nice
and sort of straightforward.
But we did
the most amazing prawn cocktail,
which was a simple appetizer.
-Yeah.
-And for entrees,
we had this amazing ribeye
that was cooked on the grill
with these duck --
duck-fat-cooked, triple-cooked
fries with truffle.
And then, for dessert,
we had just finished off
with this amazing chocolate
fondant with a milk ice cream.
Honestly, it was so delicious.
-Yeah, see, that's good.
-But, yeah.
-That's simple, though --
even though it's tricky.
But it's kind of simple, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Meat and potatoes.
You have ice cream
and chocolate sauce.
Shrimp cocktail.
"Shrimp cocktail."
[ Laughter ]
Wait. Can you say --
Can you say "shrimp cocktail"
in an American accent?
-[ Normal voice ]
Shrimp cocktail.
-[ Laughing ]
That's not even close.
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
"Master Chef Jr."
is coming back.
-Yes.
-And I do love that show.
Would you be good at any
of your shows as a contestant?
-Mate, at 8 years of age,
I was too busy trying to kick
a soccer ball around.
I think, if anything, when I
came out of Paris at, what, 23,
getting my ass kicked
in top-flight kitchens
across France,
I'd probably end up
on something like
"Hell's Kitchen,"
that sort of high-octane,
high-pressurized boot camp...
-Yeah..
-...of the culinary world.
-Would you be good?
-I'd be [bleep] amazing.
[ Laughter ]
-All right -- Gordon, that --
You can't say that.
That's two.
That's two strikes.
That's two --
That's two strikes for you.
-It's 11:35.
-That's two strikes for you.
"I'm going to put you
on the naughty step!"
[ Laughter ]
-It's 11:35.
You're allowed to cuss
after 9:00 in the U.K.
-No, it's actually flipped over.
It's already past midnight,
so now it's the morning.
[ Laughter ]
-[Bleep]
-So it's a morning show
at this point, yeah.
You know, I love you on TikTok.
It makes me laugh.
Right? Do you guys know
what I'm talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You do this amazing thing
on TikTok where you duet --
you watch someone make
something, and you just --
you ridicule them
and just make fun of them
or give them critiques.
But very --
it's very good and very funny.
And you're good at that.
I thought maybe
if I made a sandwich,
can you critique that?
[ Laughter ]
-You, as a chef?
I'd love to see what --
What would you put together?
-All right, here we go.
All right.
So I'm just gonna
make a sandwich
like I would normally
make a sandwich,
and you can talk.
I won't --
I'll try not to listen to you.
Okay?
-Okay.
-Okay, here we go.
-So...
-All right, here we go.
So I'm gonna
make a sandwich here.
I got all the spreads.
I'm gonna choose
this right here,
these two pieces of bread.
-Plain white bread?
-And I'm going to --
I don't like ham.
I don't know what that is.
-Hold on, hold on.
-I don't like cheese that much
unless it's melted, so --
And that bacon is ugh.
So, no on that.
I'm gonna go with turkey.
Oh, no.
Do I do turkey first?
-The butter, you donut.
What about some butter
on there first?
-Do I put --
Do I put mustard or something?
I like mustard.
-[Bleep] me.
What about
some hummus or mayonnaise?
How about --
-I love --
Don't even say the word
mayonnaise -- gross.
[ Laughter ]
I love mustard.
Oh, I want more turkey, right?
I can just put more.
I would never do mustard
in between the Turkey.
Oh, my God.
-Oh, my gosh.
-All right, I'm gonna put onion.
Maybe onion?
-No, you don't put raw onion --
No.
-I love that.
That looks good right there.
I'm in, like, a --
I'm in a spicy fun mood,
like you don't know
where I'm gonna end up.
So I'm gonna go a little
jalapeño on there, y'all.
Hello!
"Hi, y'all!
How y'all doing?!
How y'all doing?"
-Is that it?
-All right, let's go, bud.
Al right, and then maybe
I'll put some pickled jalapeños,
as well, on there,
for some extra --
-No.
It'll turn the bread soggy.
-For some extra zip.
And then, if you want
to talk about zip,
put a little mustard
back on this guy.
Let's zip it up one more time!
-Oh, my God, no!
-And then we want
to crunch it down?
Crunch it down then.
Don't talk to me about it.
Call me later.
Here we go.
-It's gonna --
It's gonna fall apart now.
-And do you slice it?
-No, it's gonna --
Oh, my goodness.
-No, I do it that way.
-It's gonna fall apart.
Oh, geez.
It's gonna -- oh, my gosh.
-Here we go.
-That was a sandwich nightmare
right there.
What is that thing?
-That is a turkey sandwich,
a la Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-A la Jimmy -- no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When you lift up a sandwich
and you look at it,
it should look edible.
Yours looks like
the inside of a [bleep] diaper.
[ Laughter ]
Look at --
-What's he talking about?
That's a --
[ Audience "Ews" ]
-Oh, my God.
Jimmy...
-Yeah.
-Jimmy!
-Yes!
Stop yelling!
I can hear you, man!
-Get two slices of bread
and stick them on your ears.
[ Laughter ]
-Two slices of bread
and stick them on my ears?
-Yes!
Quick!
You idiot sandwich!
What are you?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-So stupid.
Don't make me do that.
-Come on.
-You called me an idiot, too.
I told you not to do that!
[ Laughter ]
Whoo-hoo!
Gordon Ramsay,
I love having you on.
I want to talk about
"Next Level Chef."
I think it's genius.
I think --
How did you
think of this idea?
Where did it come from?
-Yeah, that's
a really good question.
So, you know how tough it's been
for the restaurant business
over the last two years,
so I said,
"Look, let's treat this moment
as a grassroots.
Let's start developing
new ideas.
Let's start reopening
these restaurants with new,
fresh ideas," and it was the
same with the production arm.
So, for the first time ever, we
put together professional chefs,
social-media chefs, and then
amateur chefs into one arena.
Stuck them
on three different levels,
and then the idea was to climb
to get to the next level.
So, this platform descends down,
you grab your ingredients,
you cook ad hoc,
with a very spontaneous insight,
and you create
across 45 minutes,
and you cook your way
to the very top.
So, yeah, super exciting.
-This is the --
This is the three levels here.
The top kitchen is all, like,
top-of-the-line stuff.
The middle kitchen is just
a normal kitchen
you see in a restaurant.
And down here is the basement,
where nothing works,
the pots are all bent, and --
[ Laughter ]
And there's the elevator where
all the food comes down.
And it is so fun to watch.
And I will say,
your co-hosts are amazing.
Nyesha Arrington...
-Richard and Nyesha.
-...Richard Blais,
they're fantastic.
Nyesha, she's tough, by the way.
-Oh, my goodness.
-I love that she --
-I swear to God.
-I love that she threw --
threw the pan off the whole set.
-Mate, you would last 30 seconds
in the kitchen with her.
-Get a life.
Get a life.
No way, man. I'd be one of
the trailblazers, man.
Know what I'm talking about?
[ Laughter ]
-You'd go down.
I promise you.
-Yeah, right.
I love the show,
and I already know who won.
-What?
-Yeah, I think I know who won.
I'm so good at this.
I'm so good.
I watched the show.
-What, with putting
a sandwich together like that
piece of [bleep]?
You know who's won?
[ Laughter ]
Mate, you got no chance.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a look
at "Next Level Chef."
Check this out.
-Come on.
-Some of the potatoes
are slightly under.
It's gonna be tight
to finish this.
Tell me -- pomme soufflé.
-Uh, I got one.
-They're not working,
drop them, right?
60 seconds.
Start dressing these plates now!
-Every detail at this point
has to be perfect.
This is it.
-5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
And stop.
Hands in the air.
Well done!
-The stress!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a great show.
Congrats, buddy.
Best to the fam.
Gordon Ramsay, everybody.
"Next Level Chef" airs
Wednesdays at 9:00 p.m. on Fox.